[Musique]
les shadows que d'en bas à eux aussi ont
décidé d'aller sur la terre pourrait
être tranquille jusqu'ici vous lirez
vous nous avons laissé ses chats doc la
faire un peu ce qu'ils voulaient sans
trop nous en occuper et nous prions nos
téléspectateurs de nous en excuser
mais il se passe est déjà tellement de
choses en eau que nous n'avons pas eu le
temps de voir ce qui se passait au bas
eh bien il s'y passe est à peu près la
même chose et si vous voulez le savoir
en détail il nous suffirait de
recommencer notre histoire à partir du
début et de vous remontrer tout comme ça
mais quand même pour résumer simplement
les choses disons que d'une part leur
eau à eux était plus bas que le bas de
ceux d'en haut et que d'autre part leurs
bas est excessivement au dessus de leurs
eaux de sorte que quand un shadok d'en
bas voulait tomber d'assez haut par
exemple il fallait qu'ils sautent de
bien plus bas que si le haut avait été
nettement au dessous c'est à dire en
réalité au dessus du bas ou quelque
chose comme ça pour le reste c'était
pareil et pour partie lille avait
construit
devinez quoi une fusée évidemment mais à
l'envers
restait à savoir si une fusée comme ça
accepter de marcher à l'envers dans un
espace à l'endroit ou inversement
[Musique]